This video is made in partnership with Nikon
Healthcare, a leader in scientific imaging
and tools.
You can learn more about their imaging technology
and microscopy solutions by visiting the link
in the description.
In labs around the world, you can find tanks
like this one.
They are filled with zebrafish, who have received
that name for obvious stripe-related reasons.
These particular zebrafish are residents of
the National Institutes of Health, where they
provide researchers with the means to study
disease and understand more about how life develops.
And here, thanks to the power of fluorescent
proteins and microscopy, we see the zebrafish
in a whole new palette, lit up in electric
shades of blue and orange.
This image is first and foremost discovery,
the result of a scientific hunt for a series
of vessels inside the zebrafish whose existence
might help scientists understand human diseases.
But we’ll get to that in a bit.
Because what we can also appreciate is that
this image is stunning.
There’s the clarity and contrast of the
colors, the sense of texture as the scales  begin to overlap.
You don’t have to understand everything
going on in this image to find it beautiful…just
like any art, really.
Which is why it’s perhaps not surprising
that in 2020, the scientist who took this
picture submitted it to the Nikon Small World
Photomicrography Competition and won.
The Nikon Small World Competition began in
1975 with the photomicrography contest, providing
a showcase for all of the spectacular imagery
that many masters of microscopes have observed
and created, using whatever subject or technique
that suits them.
And in 2011, Nikon added a new video category
called Small World in Motion.
Every year, Nikon gathers a panel of judges
to go through the submissions and decide on the winner.
And in 2021, that panel of judges included
me, your trusty Journey to the Microcosmos host Hank Green.
I was there, as you might imagine, not so
much for my technical expertise as I was to
get excited about and interested in the stories
behind the images.
And I said yes, not just for the free camera
that I did get, but also to have a couple
of days to sit around with true experts in
their fields and to get some real behind the
scenes insights into science that you can’t
really get by reading articles, and I was
not disappointed by the insights of my fellow
judges, who are true experts and were really lovely people.
The 2021 winner of the Small World in Motion
competition was this spectacular clip of symbiotic
protists that live inside of a termite’s
gut, taken and submitted by Fabian J. Weston from Australia.
Filmed with polarized light and a microscope
from the 1970s, you can see how much these
organisms resemble organisms that you have
seen in our episodes.
But these organisms have managed to carve
out a home for themselves inside of termites,
where they help their host digest wood and
other plants.
This is one of the transportive experiences
of microscopy, the way that one image can
reveal a world that is both so alien and unifying
at once.
And if there’s an animal that has embodied
that dichotomy over and over again, it is
the one we started this episode with: the
zebrafish.
Now, on the one hand, it doesn’t seem like
we should be finding a lot in common with
a striped minnow.
This is a fish that spawns eggs when daylight
breaks; that has those eggs fertilized outside
of its body; and that will produce hundreds
of offspring through this method over the
course of a week.
And their embryos develop really quickly,
assembling a head, tail, and heart within
24 hours of fertilization.
So when you hear all that—the daylight spawning,
the external fertilization, the rapid development—you
probably would not expect to find much common
ground with the zebrafish.
Except that we do share common ground—we
share about 71% of our genome with a zebrafish,
and many of those genes are valuable counterparts
to understanding human diseases.
This combination of similarities and differences
make zebrafish an extraordinary resource for scientists.
As an embryo and larva, the zebrafish is transparent.
And with the right combination of pigment
mutations, scientists have been able to create
a ghostly, translucent version of the fish
called casper.
That clarity makes it much easier for scientists
to observe the inner workings of the fish
under the microscope compared to, you know,
much more opaque animals, like us or mice.
And since zebrafish are easy to take care
of and regularly make embryos, they provide
many, many opportunities for researchers to
search for equivalents to our own selves in the fish.
In the case of the image we just showed at
the beginning of the episode, what researchers
were pursuing was a series of lymphatic vessels
inside the zebrafish’s skull.
In mammals, these vessels maintain the right
balance of fluids in our nervous system, making
them potentially important in understanding
diseases like Alzheimers.
And being able to use zebrafish to study these
vessels would be amazing…except for one
problem: no one had ever observed lymphatic
vessels in the skull of non-mammals.
No one, that is, until Daniel Castranova and
his fellow scientists in Brant Weinstein’s
lab at the NIH.
They used fluorescent proteins in transgenic
zebrafish to highlight the lymphatic vessels,
bones, and scales.
And you can see those parts of the zebrafish
here: the lymphatic vessels are shown in orange,
the bones and scales are shown in blue.
To take these images, the researchers anesthetized
a juvenile zebrafish and mounted it on agarose
to hold it still.
Then they used a confocal microscope to divide
and image the fish in layers.
It’s a bit like cutting the fish into cross-sections,
only there’s no need to make a physical cut.
The microscope creates those cross-sections
through its own optical methods.
The result is around 387 images that could
then be stitched together to create one final image.
But this image is not just a 2-D photograph.
It is a three-dimensional reconstruction,
creating a map of cells inside the zebrafish
that tells the researchers which vessels are
inside and outside the skull.
This map revealed that zebrafish have lymphatic
vessels inside their skulls.
Moreover, researchers can easily do live imaging
of these vessels.
They can even see immune cells traveling through
those vessels.
What the final product reveals is not just
something new, and not just something beautiful.
What this image reveals really is the possibility
we continue to find in zebrafish.
Much of this possibility is scientific, a
future where experiments with zebrafish contribute
to a greater understanding of disease.
There is so much work that goes into making
images like this one and all the other Nikon
Small World submissions, so much careful thought
and technique to determine how to use biology
and technology at once.
And all of it hinges on the microscope, a
scientific and artistic instrument rolled
into one that has allowed its many masters
to craft visions of worlds that contain bits
of ourselves.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Nikon Healthcare for
helping us make this video.
If you want to learn more about the imaging
technology that helps to create amazing microscopy
like what you saw in this video, make sure
to check out the link in the description,
and if you’d like to see more imagery and
video that blends science and art, check out
the microscopy galleries at NikonSmallWorld.com.
I know I have spent a lot of time there.
A big thanks to all of the people whose names
are on the screen right now.
They are our patrons on Patreon.
Patreon is a place where people support the
things that they think should exist in the world.
And all of these people have decided that
they want Journey to the Microcosmos to exist
in the world, and gosh darn it, if we don’t
agree with them.
So, thank you all so much, we obviously could
not do this without your support.
If you would like to become one of these people,
you can do that at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on instagram, and if you want
to see more from us, there’s always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby.